Now, if you're a pretty observant gadget hound
like me, you may be wondering how is it
that these bucket breakdowns actually work. My Nexus
7 tablet, for example, is only 800 pixels wide
in the portrait orientation. This Galaxy x4 phone
is actually 1080 pixels wide, in the same dimension.
Even though the S4 has more pixels, it's
somehow turning up as a phone. Why is this?
The answer lies in a little bit of magic
called the device pixel ratio, and the fact that once
again, the web platform is lying to you. The device
pixel ratio, is the ratio between device independent pixels and
an actual physical pixel on the screen. Remember, back in
the viewport lesson, when I said you should just give
this magic boilerplate at the top of your file, and
you'd get the actual number of pixels on the screen
as your width? Well, that's not actually quite true, because we've a concept
called a device independent pixel. The first time this
really came into play, was when apple released the iphone 4. The original
iphone and the iphone 3G and 3Gs, had a screen resolution
of 320 by 480. The iphone 4, however, had what apple
called a retina display, which doubled the horizontal and
vertical resolution. To 640 by 960, but they still
wanted text set in pixels to be the same
height. To go back to the viewport lesson for
a second, even with width set to device width,
they still wanted to have the same pixel width
fed to the layout algorithm, so you got consistent
layout across the iphone 3 and iphone 4. In essence,
they caused the lay out algorithm to lie
again. Even though the screen is 640 x 960,
the layout algorithm treats it like it's 320 x
480. That way, sizes that formatted for the original
320 x 480 screen still layout well on
the higher resolution screen, and text and images are
rendered at the higher resolution. So, it can look
better as well. That's why, even on the iphone
5, if you set a view port with device
width, the browser width is returned to you as
320 pixels not the actual 640 pixels that there're
across the screen. There're are 2 device pixels for
every pixel that the system lays out. The new
screen, of course, is a little bit longer. So,
the vertical dimension is different. Window.device pixel ratio captures
this ratio. The number of device pixels, for every formatting
pixel in the layout system. It's basically a way
to identify the density of pixels on the screen. Now,
this may not be the precise device pixel density.
It's sometimes rounded to the nearest integer. But, this let's
us know high resolution density the screen is, rather
than just how many layout pixels there are on it.
So, let's go back to the original question. How is
it that the Galaxy S4 is getting the phone layout
in our conference app, while my Nexus 7 is
getting the tablet layout? Even though the S4 has couple
hundred more pixels across, than the Nexus and we're using
pixel count to switch in our media query. Well, the
answer is device pixel ratio. The Galaxy S4 has
a device pixel ratio of 3. The Nexus 7 is
only 1.3. So, if you look at the formatting width,
the width passed into the viewport, the windows screen width.
Well, on the S4 it's 360. But on the Nexus 7, it's 601.